Dylan Farrow breaks down while detailing
the sexual abuse allegations against her
father Woody Allen I want to show my
face and tell my story
Dylan spoke out in her first TV
interview on Thursday CBS this morning
after claiming her adoptive dad
filmmaker Woody Allen molested her when
she was seven years old
I was sexually assaulted as a seven year
old I would say I would have said he
touched my private parts okay okay which
I did say all right all right as a 32
year old he touched my labia and my
vulva with his finger Dylan who is now
married and the mother of a one-year-old
was visibly emotional after watching a
clip where Allen denied the allegations
he also accused his ex-wife Mia Farrow
of brainwashing Dylan what else would he
do he often asked me to get into bed
with him when he had only his underwear
on and sometimes winning if only I had
my underwear on she knows and she's
expecting a backlash from people who
support Woody Allen that they're going
to come after her and going to come
after her mother neither Mia Farrow or
Dylan Farrell wanted to talk about this
back then I think it's important to
point out that Woody Allen was never
charged there was never a trial in fact
he was cleared by a report from Yale New
Haven Hospital that said that there was
no evidence of abuse following Dylan's
interview Allen released a statement
once again denying allegations writing
in part the Farrell family is cynically
using the opportunity afforded by The
Times up movement to repeat this
discredited allegation I never molested
my daughter
[Music]
you